bruxelles bruxelles est très mécontent
semble-t-il des projets d'accord sur un
certain nombre de destinations entre air
france et air inter une europe qui
commence difficilement explications de
gérard jouany
bernard attali président d'air france et
pierre helson président d'air inter ont
signé un accord de partenariat appliquée
à la france et à l'europe selon cet
accord air inter font panier intérieur
peut desservir madrid londres athènes
rome et pizzas en échange air france
peut lancer ses avions sur bordeaux lyon
marseille montpellier et nantes l'accord
fonctionne d'ailleurs fort bien mais il
n'est pas du tout du goût de la
commission européenne pour bruxelles air
france air inter pratique des ententes
en contradiction avec la libre
concurrence qui est le credo de l'europe
des 12 l'accord pourrait donc être cassé
et il obligerait le gouvernement
français à revoir sa politique aérienne
bruxelles pourrait même encore aller
plus loin et demandé à air france et ut
à de céder leurs parts dans le capital
d'air inter tout cela au nom de la libre
concurrence
ut à pourrait aussi obtenir des lignes
en europe contre la volonté du ministre
michel delebarre on le voit le paf le
paysage aérien français risquent de
trembler sous les coups du marché commun
m